that's the tricky part about doing like
an ensemble piece like this because you
put together six actors not only are you
dealing with six different personalities
you're dealing with six different ways
of working and you're dealing with six
different acting Styles one guy needs a
lot of rehearsal another guy doesn't
like any rehearsal at all one guy's
naturalistic one's one guy's method so
that's tricky how I did it I'm not exact
I don't remember uh necessarily other
than just you deal with each of them as
individuals some directors well I said
this is my way of working with actors
and boom and everyone has to adjust to
him and I think that's just ego because
you want the actor to deliver you know
deliver you the best he has and if he
has a special way of working then you
have to make things work for him and
understand that all right because you
want everyone to be their best and so
you work with it the thing that I had
going on my side was as an actor I
understood that all right I understand
the process I'm not baffled by it also
the other thing that I had on my side
there was no ego everybody was there to
make the best movie they possibly could
Everyone Cared about the film all right
there was no ego involved you know only
only love